♪ Il est venu le temps
Des cathédrales ♪
- Luc Plamondon, on vous
attrape en pleine célébration
du 20e anniversaire
de Notre-Dame de Paris.
Qu'est-ce que ça signifie
pour vous?
- Bien, ça me rajeunit
de 20 ans, déjà.
(rires)
♪ Ils sont des étrangers
Des sans-papiers ♪
♪ Des hommes et des femmes
LUC PLAMONDON, parolier
- C'est agréable parce que
ça continue. Ça ne s'arrête pas.
On va encore être là pour fêter
encore 20 ans, hein? Je crois.
♪ Ne cherche plus l'amour
Il est là ♪
♪ Il est là pour toujours
Je le crois ♪
- À chaque fois,
c'est un miracle.
On s'attendait pas
à ce qu'une chanson comme Belle
pouvait être un tube.
♪ Belle
C'est un mot qu'on dirait ♪
♪ Inventé pour elle
- On était complètement...
C'est comme Starmania, on a fait
Starmania à la période du disco.
On était complètement
à côté de la plaque.
♪ Stone
♪ Le monde est stone ♪
- Qui aurait dit que
« Stone, le monde est stone »
pouvait être un rythme chanté
dans les chaumières?
♪ Je sais pas si c'est la Terre
Qui tourne à l'envers ♪
- En préparant cette entrevue,
je me suis posé la question
suivante : pourquoi j'aimais
autant vos chansons?
Je vais penser à Coeur
de rockeur, interprété
par Julien Clerc.
♪ Avec mon coeur de rockeur
J'ai jamais su dire je t'aime ♪
- Il y a presque, dans toutes
mes chansons, un personnage
qui parle à la première personne
ou alors un personnage
que je raconte, mais
je ne raconte pas ma vie.
J'écris pas ma vie.
♪ Donnez-moi ♪
- Avec Diane Dufresne,
j'ai eu beaucoup de plaisir
parce qu'elle s'accaparait
de tout ça, de tous
ces personnages-là et elle
jouait les personnages.
Elle n'avait pas besoin
de les jouer, elle les vivait.
Et c'était extraordinaire.
C'est une très grande interprète
comme il n'y en a plus.
♪ Donnez-moi
Donnez-moi de l'oxygène ♪
- L'autre jour, au dépanneur
à Outremont, il y a madame
en fourrure qui débarque
de sa limousine et elle rentre
dans l'épicerie et elle
se retourne vers moi. Quand elle
me voit, puis elle me dit :
« Ah! Monsieur Plamondon,
vous avez enchanté nos vies! »
C'est beau, hein?
- Oui, oui. C'est beau.
- C'est beau. Un beau cadeau.
♪ Je sais pas si c'est la Terre
Qui tourne à l'envers ♪
- J'ai une question piège,
mais je veux m'amuser :
Luc Plamondon, quelles sont,
selon vous, vos chansons
les plus réussies?
- C'est sûr que, si on
me demande la plus belle,
je pense que c'est Le monde
est stone, parce que c'est
une chason qui... On ne sait pas
comment elle est faite.
♪ Stone
Le monde est stone ♪
- Les chansons de Starmania,
c'est quelque chose
d'à part, complètement.
C'est au-dessus de tout.
♪ Comme tous ces automates
Qui bâtissent des empires ♪
- C'est difficile d'aller
plus haut après, mais, après,
je me suis amusé à faire
beaucoup de chansons pour
justement, pour Julien Clerc,
pour Nanette Workman,
pour Charlebois, etc.
♪ M'as-tu vu courir
Dans ta rue ♪
♪ Je t'aime comme un fou
- Maintenant, Luc Plamondon,
quelle est la suite pour vous?
- Là, je suis en train
de faire une comédie musicale.
Depuis dix ans que je travaille
là-dessus, sur des musiques
de Schubert, bon. Bien, ce sera
peut-être le prochain...
(rires)
C'est Kent Nagano qui m'a dit...
qui m'a embarqué là-dedans.
Et puis donc il m'a dit l'autre
jour : « Je m'en vais
dans deux ans. Dépêche-toi. »
(rires)
J'en ai une autre
qui est cachée, mais ça,
ce sera pour plus tard.
J'ai écrit une comédie musicale
qui se passe à moitié
dans le monde amérindien.
Moi, j'ai une ancêtre huronne,
mon arrière-grand-mère.
Et c'est en 90 qu'on a commencé
à faire ça avec François
Cousineau. Et puis, il y a eu
la crise d'Oka, qui a fait
qu'on ne pouvait plus faire
ce sujet-là. C'est sûr
qu'il faudrait le faire
avec des vrais Autochtones.
Mais là, Robert Lepage m'a dit :
« Tu as intérêt à mettre ça
sur la glace pour le moment. »
(rires)
Donc on verra.
- Luc Plamondon, merci beaucoup.